we are cleared into the area verified
cameras are on all right here we go
three two one here comes
all right that was awesome
I wasn't ready to make a sequel until we
had a special story worthy of a sequel
and until technology evolved so we could
delve deeper into the experience of a
fighter pilot the first movie became
something that changed a generation so
this is exciting to come back and get in
those Jets again
we worked with the Navy and the Top Gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're going to do
it we're going to fly in the f-18s
the aviation sequences had to be real
so our actors went through three months
of ruling training the Navy says if you
eject you have to be able to survive in
the water so we had to go through that
challenging underwater program it's
intense you're flipped inverted and
you're having to try and get out
from there Tom designed this
all-encompassing Aviation training for
all the actors
I started mounting a single-engine
airplane to build up their spatial
awareness inside the aircraft oh wow
to the l-39
went and flew aerobatics to feel what
it's like in a gym
from there they'd graduate to the F-18
Super Hornet and actually launching off
an aircraft carried
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially okay I'm rolling I had to
really teach them cinematography even
the lighting so that they understood
what's going to look good on camera
right everybody thought it would be
impossible for actors to really be in
the Jets
it's the gift that Tom gave us that by
the time we got up there we could handle
it
definitely the most amazing thing I've
ever done all the training 100 prepared
I'm very proud of what we all
accomplished each one of them are
extraordinary
it still blows my mind that we've done
this there's nothing like it
foreign